the Irish Prime Minister Lee over at
cope when the last half there has said
that all schools colleges and child
capsule is in Ireland will close until
March 29th let's turn to our deputy
political editor Sam Coates who's in
Downing Street where the kobra Committee
will be meeting today they will look in
Northern Ireland southwards and see a
very different regime in place Sam yes
I've just come out of the number-10
briefing the questions it has to be said
about covin 19 are starting to get a bit
trickier than they were a week or so ago
as questions about why the United
Kingdom's handling of the condition does
look to be a bit different to that some
parts the rest of the world including
now Ireland where as you say lis over AG
has made that dramatic announcement in
the last year Downing Street says that
Britain the United Kingdom will maintain
a single approach for now in other words
the approach taken in Great Britain
which at the moment and we await a
likely press conference later today will
be to keep schools open to trying to not
have stopped public gatherings and that
will continue in Northern Ireland yet
the approach just south of that
invisible border would be a seemed to be
so different this poses so many
questions is it that because of maybe
different healthcare systems that
scientists in the UK and scientists in
the Republic simply believe that the
approach is different or is it because
we that the condition is different or is
the science different it's very
difficult to tell
you